President Trump is touting his own
influence and high Republican turnout in
primary elections held yesterday in
eight states much of the focus of course
was on California where the state's
unusual jungle format could have locked
out one party completely out of the
November races correspondent Peter Doocy
is in Del Mar tonight with an update
California's gubernatorial primary
didn't have a blue wave instead a
Republican Riptide make California the
Golden State once again with that
familiar sounding slogan after a strong
finish that put him on the ballot
Republican John Cox is channelling
President Trump while Democrat Gavin
Newsom is tweeting to him urging the
commander-in-chief to go further than
just congratulating the candidate he
helped with an endorsement with this
quote pleasecome campaign for him as
much as possible voters will have a real
choice this November between a governor
who was gonna stand up to Donald Trump
and a foot soldier in his war but Cox is
correcting Newsom and it wasn't donald
trump that passed the sanctuary state
Gavin you did that for weeks
California's airwaves were blanketed
with campaign commercials but turnout
was still a soft 21 point nine percent
three percent lower than the 2014
gubernatorial primary some voters ran
into trouble because a printing problem
in LA County left 118 thousand residents
off the rolls at 1500 precincts in some
of those it was as many as a few hundred
it wasn't just a long night for the LA
Registrar it took hours to learn that
Democratic Senator Dianne Feinstein who
failed to win the state party's
endorsement would be challenged by the
more progressive state senator Kevin de
Lyonne it also took a while until
results in Orange County's expensive
primaries began to trickle in and when
they did Democrats were relieved to have
seen candidates claw their way onto
ballots everywhere including districts
they risked coming in third place too
low for the November ballot the
Democratic Congressional Campaign
Committee says it's data-driven
investments to California will continue
to pay dividends in November and Beyond
talk like that
impress one incumbent who won with a
healthy margin last night Republican
congressman Dana Rohrabacher Republicans
are defending 10 House seats here and
found out late last night they've got
something new to offer voters who are
also hearing from a very energized
Democratic base and that is the
opportunity to vote for the first
Republican governor to elect the first
Republican governor in this state since
Schwarzenegger Shannon
well everybody agrees he's got an uphill
battle but we've seen other things
happen Peter Doocy thank you very much
for your reporting out there in
California